government is not a monolithic thing
which is your enemy it's a multitudinous
thing which is your enemy
our dream was to enable the future of
human freedom in the early 1990s a group
of mathematicians misfits hackers and
hobbyists came together around a shared
belief that the internet would either
demolish artificial walls or lay the
groundwork for an orwellian state we can
prevent the ministry of truth
they saw a branch of mathematics called
cryptography as a weapon against central
planning and surveillance in this new
virtual world and what is a cypher
cyberpunks are cryptography activists
the more i realized how it was a really
pivotal technology for society
the national security agency declared
the unrestrained public discussion of
cryptographic research threatened our
national security i saw this as the
critical fork in the road for the future
of human freedom coming up reason
presents a four-part series and a
movement that foresaw both the promise
and the peril that lay ahead when the
internet upended the world it's like
standing on top of the mountain and
seeing that this is out there you people
who are here can say okay what kind of
world do we really want to build and
build it
[Music]
imagine if you will sitting down to your
morning coffee turning on your home
computer to read the day's newspaper
well it's not as far-fetched as it may
seem
the freedom issues were very important
to us this is an example of what you can
order through your computer
it combines the power of your computer
with the convenience of your telephone
we saw that information technology could
create a 1984 style tyrannical top-down
control society or it could develop into
something that is a decentralized
enabler of human freedom
and even back then our dream was to
enable the future of human freedom
in the late 1980s at the dawn of the
online age a group of young computer
scientists in silicon valley started
grappling with what this new technology
would mean for society we took a look at
the potential of computer systems
and saw that for everything about
civilization that enables it to work we
can enable it to work much better the
most influential figure in what would
become the cypherpunk movement was the
physicist tim may who envisioned the
future internet as a place for what he
would dub crypto anarchy where
lawbreakers radicals and political
dissidents could shield their activities
from government surveillance and control
people doing things that didn't require
permissions from anyone because the
people were untraceable it couldn't be
stopped but there was another group that
saw the potential of computers to remake
society gradually from within by
decentralizing commerce and improving
the dissemination of knowledge they were
dubbed the high-tech hiaquids because
their worldview was influenced by the
work of austrian economist friedrich
hayek the fundamental insights of
hayeking economics was how separately
formulated plans tend to mesh well and
we saw electronic media as a
enabler of coordination the complexity
that the world previously was really not
capable of the clash of visions between
the high-tech hayekians who wanted to
build a borderless frictionless global
marketplace and the crypto anarchists
who saw the internet as a technological
means of undermining all governments set
the course for the cypherpunk movement
if may was the father of cryptoanarchy
the central figure for the high-tech
hayekians was the economist and
entrepreneur phil salen now if you own a
personal computer we are told you can
shop at home in what's called the
electronic mall it was a few years
before the invention of the world wide
web but computer companies were offering
a new type of service in which customers
could connect through their phone lines
to post messages to a bulletin board
check their horoscopes or go shopping
you can buy items from department stores
ranging from nordstrom's to neiman
marcus all via computer screen
salen whose outlook was shaped by his
careful reading of hayek understood that
these services weren't merely a
curiosity or a digital version of the
old mail order catalog they were the
beginning of something that had the
potential to one day erase national
boundaries through trade and undermine
government power
in a prescient 1991 essay he foresaw how
the internet would change the world by
1995 2000 and beyond the static role of
store and shopper seller and buyer
author and reader systems defined by
their one-way information flows will be
replaced by new forms of media enabling
two-way information flows
before getting involved with computers
salen had run a private rocket company
and had co-authored a congressional
study critical of nasa's wasteful
spending but in his view there was
continuity between his interests in
space travel and computing because in
both industries technology's purpose was
to drive down the transaction costs that
impede human activity making it feasible
to explore new frontiers and interact in
ways that would otherwise be
prohibitively expensive
now thanks to breakthroughs in computing
the ability to buy or obtain exactly the
information you need when you want it in
the form you want it is about to explode
at a speed unmatched since the invention
of printing
but salen was foremost an entrepreneur
and in the mid-1980s he set out to
launch one of those platforms for buying
and selling information
he called it the american information
exchange or amex this business that
we're doing is to make possible a new
kind of thing which is being able to buy
and sell information
online amex was a radical idea in the
mid 1980s users could buy or sell advice
about the real estate market writing
software or what companies to invest in
now you can say to somebody so it's like
ebay or like priceline or like amazon
when we tried to explain this to people
they simply couldn't get it they could
not wrap their heads around this some of
them i think couldn't imagine the
computational end of it milton friedman
didn't get it though it was similar in
ways to the online marketplaces that
would launch a decade later amex was
more than just an idea before its time
what set it apart was its grounding in
political philosophy and its lofty goal
of elevating individual decision making
over central planning it was an
instantiation of austrian economics
now put into code and put online
something like this could have profound
human consequences and that was the
vision
a fluid transaction-oriented market
system with two-way feedback salen wrote
would result in crowding out monolithic
mostly government bureaucracies
we were laying the philosophical
foundations of what is e-commerce that
you can now have creative explosion it's
going to change the world yes that's
right
intermediating among large populations
of human beings through electronic means
results in all kinds of fascinating
emergent social behavior amex's chief
architect was the pioneering software
engineer chip morningstar who had come
from a stint at george lucas's
production studio where he oversaw the
creation of habitat which was one of the
first online virtual communities after
joining amex morningstar co-authored an
essay which argued that in building a
world in software detailed central
planning is impossible the world is just
more complicated people are more
complicated you cannot know what all
their goals are what you can do is you
can put them into an environment in
which certain kinds of things are
possible what you can't do is tell
people what they want
phil sale and mark miller and chip
morningstar's ideas about how a future
internet could decentralize society
inspired tim may to first articulate a
radically different vision may who would
go on to become the most influential
figure in the cypherpunk movement was
introduced to salem by morningstar in
december of 1987. chip said there's this
guy out in santa cruz that you ought to
talk to
as a scientist at intel may had solved
an issue affecting the reliability of
the company's memory chips called the
alpha particle problem rich on stock
options he'd been spending his days at
the beach reading science fiction novels
thinking about how networked personal
computers could turn some of their
futuristic scenarios into reality so i
met with phil in redwood city and he
described how amex would work and i said
people aren't going to be selling
meaningless stuff like surfboard
recommendations in may's view amex could
be useful as a tool for undermining
state power but only by shattering legal
and social norms i said it's going to be
corporate information it's going to be
bomber plans for the b1 bomber who wants
to buy that a competitor a company who
wants to sell that someone who has
access to that information it's two
different types of libertarians he
didn't understand the extent to which
you could benefit the world by lowering
transaction costs for everybody
like salem in the high-tech kayakians
may saw the personal computer as
enabling technology for sweeping
societal changes but he had a different
vision of a virtual marketplace for any
and all goods and services which he
dubbed blacknet or a technological means
of undermining all governments
on amex user activity was out in the
open but black net would be impervious
to government tracking and surveillance
and perhaps it would be a network with
no owners at all
many people's first response would be to
say that black net won't be allowed to
happen perhaps but technology would
probably make it inevitable
if you don't physically meet the person
if you don't even know what continent
they're on you can't coerce them
tim may's a smart guy he you know he was
great for
honing our ideas and technologies
against but you know i think him as sort
of the shock jock for uh cypherpunks
i want to live in the world that
surrounds us rather than try and
construct one from scratch
we saw this as emerging from inside the
world and carrying the world along with
it
in 1988 amex was acquired by the
software giant autodesk a growing scene
of young technologists came together
around salem and the high-tech kayakians
all working towards a common vision of
enhancing human freedom through
networked personal computing it was this
hot house of ideas from which a world
view was brewing
salem died of cancer in 1991 the same
year that the world wide web became
publicly available but his intellectual
contributions and conflict with may had
laid the groundwork for what would come
next for the cypherpunks the long effort
to build a self-sovereign and anonymous
form of digital money and the embrace of
a branch of mathematics called
cryptography which they came to view as
the key to personal liberation on the
internet
[Music]
the title of the book is the rise of the
computer state what i'm saying is that
large bureaucracies with the power that
the computer gives them become more
powerful and that they are escaping the
checks and balances of representative
democracy
in 1983 the new york times reporter
david burnham warned that the
integration of computers into every
aspect of daily life could lead to a
level of automated surveillance unknown
in any previous age for society to
change course burnham argued citizens
would need to rise up through the
democratic process and demand new legal
protections to safeguard their privacy
there are ways to deal with it we have
done it and all i hope is that we're on
our toes enough and
alert enough to
see them and go after them this is just
political jaw boning a few years later a
physicist named tim may argued that
putting faith in representative
democracy was naive he believed that
only innovation could save us from the
orwellian state the interesting things
that had happened had been technological
changes the telephone copy machine the
vcr
computers
may became a co-founder of the
cypherpunk movement which came together
around the idea that a recent
breakthrough in the field of
cryptography was the key innovation for
combating tyranny comparable to how the
crossbow enabled individuals to go up
against medieval armies it's an epiphany
it's like standing on top of the
mountain and seeing that this is out
there
coming up reason takes a look at how one
community came to see cryptography as a
powerful weapon for defeating big
brother here's part two in a four part
series on how the cypherpunk movement
anticipated the promise and the peril
that lay ahead when the internet upended
the world
[Music]
in the late 1970s there was an
astonishing breakthrough in the field of
cryptography
i saw this as the critical fork in the
road for the future of human freedom i
really did
in the summer of 77 mark miller was a 20
year old student at yale working for a
counter-cultural tech visionary named
ted nelson like many future cypherpunks
he would learn of this groundbreaking
discovery when the august issue of
scientific american arrived at his door
and i'm reading
[Music]
i'm reading martin gardner's
mathematical games column i just get
incredibly excited just incredibly
excited i call up ted in the middle of
the night and i tell ted we can prevent
the ministry of truth
as gardner told his readers a discovery
had been made that would revolutionize
the entire field of secret communication
it was the work of teams of
mathematicians and computer scientists
at mit and stanford
including a young researcher named
whitfield diffie
if you look at
1791 at the moment of the bill of rights
impenetrably private conversations
dominated what the framers didn't
foresee is that private communication
would happen via computers sending
messages across the world that could
easily be intercepted public key
cryptography gives you a mechanism
whereby you can recover this ability to
have an impenetrably private
conversation between two people
look at this a cipher well let's go back
to the office and get started on it
sending a secret message used to involve
translating words through a secret code
that spies in government agents could
potentially crack
phil
i think i've got it good
z
is d
v
is e anyone sending and receiving
messages also had to have a copy of the
secret key or translation device just
like the decipher rings collected by
american school children starting in the
1930s here's how you can get one for
your very own
first get a jar of chocolate flavored
ovaltine public key cryptography made
decoding devices unnecessary and
figuring out the pattern effectively
impossible
the big breakthrough was an easy to
solve mathematical formula that you
could funnel words into just as easily
as dropping them through a trap door
but if you flip the problem around and
tried to pull the message out the other
side in that direction the formula was
almost impossible to solve such that
even a super computer trying random
numbers would need 40 quadrillion years
to service the answer but the person who
set up the mathematical formula or
trapdoor held the answer to the problem
or secret code making it possible for
that person to retrieve the original
message
it could also be compared to the most
ubiquitous trapdoor system for sending
messages consider a mailbox anyone can
throw a letter in a mailbox but only the
mailman who has a key can take it out
anyone in the world could set up one of
these equations serving as the mailman
of his or her very own impenetrable
virtual letterbox and because that
individual could prove ownership of the
mailbox by opening it with the only
known key public key cryptography also
made it possible to set up a provable
identity on the internet completely
disconnected from any real-world
personal information
knowing economics what you do and
looking at what's happening with the
internet what do you
what can you see happening way out there
in the future the most striking
non-obvious thing
is that current technologies are in the
process of giving us a level of privacy
we have never had before essentially
there are now
well-known
ways available in free software of
encrypting messages so that only the
intended recipient can read them so that
if the fbi intercepts them it's
gibberish to them
one way of reading the second amendment
is that it was a way of making sure that
if the government tried to suppress the
people the people would win and the
militia wouldn't be very good but it
would outnumber the professionals
in the modern world
the weapons that the army has differ by
a lot more than they did in the 18th
century
but i also think that if you look at
what politics are like nowadays the real
wars between the government and the
population are information wars not
physical wars encryption means that they
can't arrest you they can't blackmail
your
your
your key people can't do any of the
things governments might do
to make sure that public information is
what they wanted
meanwhile the u.s intelligence community
was doing everything in its power to
keep this new tool out of the hands of
the public well somebody once said to me
if you think new directions had an
impact on the outside world you should
have seen the impact it had at nsa
in part three in this series we'll look
at the u.s government's effort to halt
the widespread use of public key
cryptography by threatening criminal
prosecution
and the legal and public relations
battle waged by one founding member of
the cypherpunks for freedom of speech
and software
[Music]
a hurricane of unrestrained joy sweeps
through every part of a war sick world
the breaking of encryption was essential
to the war effort
[Music]
england would probably have fallen if
they'd not been able to read the enigma
messages because every time the germans
sent bombers the raf knew where they
were sending them and could mass the
planes there to defend if any
significant fraction of those attacks
had gotten through england would have
been much more helpless may well have
fallen in the world course of world war
ii may have changed and that is the
origin of the regulations that said this
is a munition this is an item of war and
the problem was they didn't really take
freedom of speech freedom of inquiry
academic freedom into account in that
but on the matter of encryption
terrorists are going to have these are
law enforcement
and get vital information i think that's
the same choice coming up the story of
the us government's long battle to keep
strong encryption out of the hands of
its citizens and how first amendment
activists fought back
here's part three in a four part series
on how the cypherpunk movement of the
1990s anticipated the promise and the
peril that lay ahead when the internet
upended the world
[Music]
in 1977 researchers at mit made an
astonishing discovery a mathematical
system for encrypting secret messages so
powerful that it had the potential to
make government spying effectively
impossible
but before these mathematicians could
publish their research the nsa made it
clear that doing so could land them in
federal prison
the u.s government considered these
mathematical systems modern weapons
technologies and distributing them was a
crime under the international traffic
and arms regulations mit halted plans to
distribute the paper
i decided quite literally
they are going to classify this over my
dead body
mark miller was a 20 year old student at
yale who had read about this discovery
in scientific american so i traveled to
mit managed to get my hand on a paper
copy of this thing i went to a variety
of different copy shops so i wasn't
making lots of copies in any one place i
sent them to home and hobbyist computer
organizations and magazines all across
the country and i gave copies of the
paper to some select friends of mine and
i told them
if i disappear
make sure this gets out
early in 1978 the u.s federal government
backed off and decided to allow the
publication and the world has been on a
different course ever since it got
published
but the crypto wars were just getting
started in the late 70s the national
security agency declared the
unrestrained public discussion of
cryptographic research threatened our
national security the private
cryptography community and the
government have been sparring over the
issue ever since
marshall mcluhan said that one day we
would all live in a global village well
the global village has arrived and its
main street is called the internet the
internet also created an electronic
surveillance apparatus there was like
nothing the world had ever seen which
meant that the cryptography
breakthroughs of the 1970s were no
longer a rarified topic they were
privacy salvation internet users could
shield their online activities from
spying and that sent the intelligence
community once again scrambling to stop
the dissemination of this powerful tool
in 1991 a software developer named phil
zimmerman released the first relatively
easy to use secret messaging system
built with strong encryption which was
called pgp
somehow it got overseas now that it's
over there people are using it and i'm
delighted to hear good stories about how
it's used in places where
there are oppressive governments so the
u.s justice department launched a
three-year criminal investigation of
zimmerman on the grounds that by making
his software accessible outside the
country he could be guilty of exporting
weapons under the arms control act
meanwhile the national security agency
argued that zimmerman's software would
be used by child molesters and criminals
pgp they say is out there to protect
freedom fighters in latvia said the
nsa's general counsel but the fact is
the only use that has come to the
attention of law enforcement agencies is
a guy who is using pgp so the police
could not tell what little boys he had
seduced over the net child pornographers
terrorists money wanderers take your
pick these are the people who will be
invoked as the bringers of death and
destruction well it's true it's true
it's true
so they're right
yes
but all technologies have had bad
effects the telephones allow extortion
death threats bomb threats kidnapping
cases
uncontrolled publishing of books could
allow satanic books to appear
the cypherpunks argued that pgp was like
any other published material because
under the hood it was just a series of
instructions to be carried out by a
machine restraint on freedom of
expression of software writers is
anathema in a free society and a
violation of the first amendment wrote
the economist and entrepreneur phil
salen in a 1991 essay titled freedom of
speech and software
encryption can't be controlled whether
or not it's powerful or has impacts on
the government because it's free speech
in the early 90s john gilmore who was a
co-founder of the cypherpunk movement
risked going to jail in his campaign to
force the government to acknowledge that
regulating encryption violated the first
amendment we basically had a community
of a thousand people scattered around
who were all trying different ideas on
how to get around the government to get
encryption to the masses
what we're afraid of several years from
now is the terrorists both hit their
encryption button on the telephone and
even though we have access we can't
understand what they're saying on a
real-time basis the clinton
administration told congress that
americans have no constitutional right
to choose their own method of encryption
and push for legislation that would
require companies to build in a
mechanism for law enforcement agencies
to break in we're in favor of strong
encryption robust encryption we just
want to make sure we have a trap door
and a key
under some judge's authority
where we can get there if
if somebody is planning a crime the
cypherpunks look for ways to undercut
the government's case by pointing out
the similarities between encryption
software and other forms of protected
speech
with phil zimmerman under federal
investigation for making his software
available for download outside the us to
prove a point he convinced mit press to
mirror his action in the analog world by
printing out the pgp source code adding
a binding and shipping it to european
bookstores the government knew if they
went to court to suppress the
publication of a book from a university
that they would lose
and they would lose in a hurry there
were people who actually got encryption
code tattooed on their bodies and then
started asking can i go to a foreign
country
we printed up t-shirts that had
encryption code on them and submitted
them to the government office of
munitions control can we publish this
t-shirt
ultimately they never answered that
query because they realized to say no
would be to invite a lawsuit they would
lose and so the best answer was no
answer at all talk a little bit more
about encryption technology no no
thank you
i i hesitate even to make use the word
but i'm not using it any more way
in 1996 the justice department announced
that it wouldn't pursue criminal charges
against phil zimmerman and major court
victories came when two federal judges
found that encryption is protected by
the first amendment the crypto wars are
still ongoing what we won in the first
round was the right to publish it and
the right to put it in mass-market
software but what we didn't actually do
is deploy it in mass-market software
now there are major companies building
serious encryption into their products
and we're getting a lot of pushback from
the government about this we're about
the rule of law but we don't want to
create spaces that are beyond the reach
of the law in the united states right
it's not just the reprehensible behavior
of sexual predation on children but
myriad additional forms of serious crime
enabled by end-to-end
encryption
i'm not optimistic that privacy will
prevail in the crypto wars
it's an ongoing struggle
in the early 90s at the same time that
gilmore was fighting his legal battle
for freedom of speech and software the
cypherpunks were exploring
cryptography's potential in the context
of collapsing political borders and the
rise of liberal democracy part four in
this series will look at how those
dreams turn to disillusionment the death
of the cypherpunk movement and its
rebirth following the invention of
bitcoin
you're looking at this and going wow
wouldn't it be amazing if this worked
and then you realized oh my gosh it does
work national borders are just speed
bumps in the information super high
cryptography is really really strong we
can do whatever we want people might
provide the equivalent of what
government does in a decentralized
fashion i talk about collapse of
governments i think we actually saw that
in the middle ages probably as a result
of the printing press
this is the story of a community of
scientists mathematicians philosophers
and activists who believe that the
internet combined with recent
breakthroughs in the field of
cryptography would upend society and
usher in a new era of sovereign
individualism
we have it in our power to begin the
world over again right now and it's
internal clash over the optimal path to
achieving that goal can evil be done
with this technology yes
and so what so then deal with it
here's the final installment in a
four-part series on the origins of the
cypherpunk movement and how it helped
shape our modern world
[Music]
[Music]
we see a free world that has achieved a
level of prosperity unprecedented in all
human history mr gorbachev
tear down this wall
if you had asked me 10 years ago is it
possible that communism could collapse
by the year 1992 that i would have said
absolutely ridiculous
the fall of the berlin wall was
important to me because i thought it was
the end of history and that national
borders would cease being
the walls of
prisons
and so a couple years later when i
discovered the internet i thought oh
this is part of this pattern where
borders and distance stop being barriers
to people
then i discovered a whole
clan of people who self-identified as
computer people
found my tribe and among that clan was
the cypherpunk's mailing list
if you want to subscribe to our mailing
list send a blank email message and just
say subscribe cyberpunks and what is a
cypherpunk what do you guys stand for
cyberpunks are cryptography activists
the cypherpunk's email list which
started in the fall of 1992 one year
after the launch of the world wide web
became a gathering place for a global
community interested in using
cryptography to allow individuals to
communicate and transact on the internet
privately and without interference from
a central authority in the last 20 years
the basic techniques to do all sorts of
impossible seeming things
have suddenly emerged put them into
practice many cypherpunks were inspired
by the work of the computer scientist
david chong who demonstrated that it was
possible to use cryptography to build an
anonymous payment network that ran on
the internet because of the cypherpunks
and because of the science papers of
david chom i thought the third thing is
going to happen is economic freedom that
people are going to be no longer
constrained by national borders and
distance
from cooperating and sharing resources
and
helping each other but at this watershed
moment of collapsing borders there was a
divide within the cypherpunk community
over whether these cryptographic tools
would lead to more individual freedom
free trade in the spread of democracy or
the end of government altogether the
cypherpunk movement's most influential
figure was the physicist and
intellectual provocateur tim may who
coined the phrase cryptoanarchy he saw
the fall of the berlin wall as evidence
that the societal institutions we take
for granted could collapse in short
order just as they had in the middle
ages we saw the little principalities
the monarchies the religious the papal
states we saw those collapse probably as
a result of publishing printing
may penned a one-page summary of how
cryptography would upend society so i
just sat down at my little macintosh and
loosely patterned this after the
communist manifesto the spectre is
haunting the modern world the specter of
crypto anarchy
cryptography is really really strong
we can be protected from anything
without from
the observers from the watchers from the
imposers of the past upon the future
we're trying to create
may was skeptical of the idea that
humanity was witnessing an unabashed
victory of economic and political
liberalism or that it was possible to
overcome tyranny through collective
action as the political scientist
francis fukuyama argued we as human
beings want to be recognized with a
certain dignity this is the essential
driving force behind democratic
revolutions whether they take place in
eastern europe or in asia or in latin
america may embraced a technology-based
theory of historic change summed up by
the movement's tagline which was coined
by the mathematician eric hughes
cypherpunk's write code what eric meant
by cypherpunk's right code is don't be
one of those guys who goes to a
libertarian party conference and sits
about getting somebody elected to the
los gatos city council
that way lies madness
whereas the interesting things that had
happened had been technological changes
the telephone the copy machine the vcr
the philosophy that i really got
interested in is that you don't just go
and ask the regulator oh we need more
privacy online we go fix it arguing and
complaining and lobbying and politics
have nominal effect on what changes the
world is technology adoption
and
you know society moving
shifting spew points
for crypto anarchists like may writing
code meant building systems for
anonymous transactions on the internet
that made the arbitrary divisions of the
political world irrelevant national
borders are just speed bumps on the
information super highway
online cryptographic networks would be
structured like a geodesic dome a form
hailed by the countercultural
technologists of the 1970s for being in
harmony with nature and highly resistant
to external attack networks with no
owners with many interconnecting nodes
that would be basically unstoppable
in a geodesic market economics will no
longer be the handmaiden of politics the
cypherpunk writer robert hettinger noted
and nation-states will eventually be as
ceremonial as modern-day constitutional
monarchs this idea of a many to many
connection was clearly going to happen
but it was much easier to build a
functional network for cooperation and
trade when you can rely on a central
authority to enforce the rules how can
we
use this weird crypto technique to solve
this strange esoteric little problem
that in the real world you just solve
because
oh i know what your social security
number is or you have to have your you
know government issued id that you know
you take into the bank so you can open
up your bank account and they can link
the two together and say okay if jim
mccoy walks out on this hundred thousand
dollar loan well we know where to find
them i was trying to deal with those
problems you can buy and sell property
in cyberspace using cryptographic
protocols the idea of ways in which
people might provide the equivalent of
what government does in a decentralized
fashion tim stole some ideas from my
machinery of freedom and he reprocessed
them with all this technology and then i
stole them back a function of government
that was particularly hard to replicate
using cryptography was the issuance of
money the cypherpunks attempted to build
a borderless internet currency system as
anonymous as cash and that like gold
held its value without the backing of a
central bank gold makes very good money
because nobody can manufacture more of
it very readily pretty mildly right
whereas bits are perfectly copyable so
turning bits into good money is quite
difficult tim me and many others
considered electronic cash to be the
holy grail because it completed the
picture a private and decentralized
monetary system may argued was a key
component in constructing a new
borderless world where the activities
and assets of individuals would be
resistant to government control and
confiscation
you don't physically meet the person if
you don't even know what continent
they're on you can't coerce them
[Music]
but there was another faction within the
movement that rejected tim may's vision
of cordoning off a new world in
cyberspace
the high-tech kayakings were people like
eric drexler mark miller phil salem
they were focused on designing secure
computing systems based on economic
insights particularly those of the
austrian-born nobel prize winner
friedrich hayek instead of building a
new virtual world shielded from
government interference the high-tech
hayekians sought to use technology to
demolish walls and divisions within the
existing world
they imagined that introducing new tools
for human coordination would gradually
erode the government's ability to
impinge on our freedoms we did lots and
lots of fantasizing about how the world
could be different but we saw this as
emerging from inside the world
cryptography was a tool for porting
economic concepts and legal structures
onto the internet but the aim was to
foster new forms of peer-to-peer
commerce and knowledge sharing and the
high-tech kayakings believe that even
imperfect systems can transform society
gradually from within
the overall arc of world history is
towards rule of law towards less
corruptible systems if
the emergence of the world of crypto
commerce creates systems that are vastly
less corruptible
but under a whole mix of different
mechanisms and governance regimes
such that
they're not always everywhere
uncorruptable
i think that's fine
there's a lot of power in providing
people tools such that they can
successfully start to act more like you
would like them to as opposed to you've
got to come over here where it's really
hard edge encrypted and it works exactly
the way we want no no you know let's
let's you know raise people's levels
incrementally and and that's an
improvement in the world
for many cypherpunks the darker side of
cryptoanarchy was epitomized by the
writings of the chemist and electrical
engineer jim bell a participant on the
email list who in the mid
compared aggression by the state to that
of muggers rapists robbers and murderers
and posited a cryptographically
protected marketplace in which anonymous
individuals could in effect pay to have
government employees killed with the
goal of destroying the state
in 1997 bell was arrested and went to
prison for among other things dropping a
stink bomb on a government building tim
may distanced himself from bell's
writings and activities while
maintaining that marketplaces for
assassination like the one bell had
described might be both inevitable and
desirable
can evil be done with
this technology not just the internet
but especially the crypto part of it yes
and so what so then deal with it
and zimmerman once told me
that he sometimes regretted ever
introducing pgp to the world because it
could be used by al qaeda or the taliban
or whatnot
i say so what
i'm not morally responsible
would have happened whether we had
existed or not
because technology has its own logic
and people want to do what they want to
do i mean
they want free [ __ ]
they want freedom to do things even if
they say this should be regulated
they'll often
make the conscious decision to copy
music
copy videotapes they want to see
black net is a negative consequence i'm
not interested in creating that
when you build technology to solve
problems then you create then there are
there are consequences that we try to
think ahead of and look at and figure
out how we might address and get ahead
of the the downsides of what we build
and that's responsible development and
we certainly engaged in that and
and and and talking with tim may and and
putting on that you know what if i was a
black cat kind of thing was certainly a
useful foil
for working through those kinds of ideas
but that's absolutely not what
cypherpunks were
so the progress of the spread of
democracy you know if you take a
sufficiently long-term view of it has
been really
quite remarkable
our dream was to enable the future of
human freedom and we had this bizarre
confidence about how the future would
unfold and to you know using alan cave's
famous phrase to have a huge hand in
inventing it
but
the road had a lot more
weeds and detours than we could have
anticipated when we first launched we
were hoping for you know maybe 400 500
people now we're at 100 000 people so
who knows where we're going using the
ever-growing storage capacity of servers
belonging to companies like google
instead of it being on your server under
your desk that stuff is being taken care
of for you professionals keep track of
all the programs and who doesn't want a
simpler life i find this way of working
half a gigabyte of information on your
customers what do you do with that they
want to know everything about you so
they can sell you stuff and it results
in you each getting a digital proctology
exam tnsa specifically targets the
communications of everyone
over the next quarter century the
internet would make possible an
explosion of individual freedom and
information sharing just as phil salen
had predicted in 1991 but it would also
grow into a surveillance apparatus that
bore out the dystopian vision of
journalist david burnham in his 1983
book the rise of the computer state
large bureaucracies with the power that
the computer gives them become more
powerful and they are escaping the
checks and balances of representative
democracy
facebook collects information that the
east german stasi would have killed for
i think that most people are quite happy
to hand people all of the information
about them online in return for
a few pics of your high school friends
kids or whatever by the mid-2000s it
seemed the cypherpunk movement had
mostly failed then came a global
financial crisis followed by massive
bailouts by central banks
on october 31st 2008 a pseudonymous
inventor named satoshi nakamoto shared a
white paper describing a new
peer-to-peer non-governmental monetary
system pulling together technical and
philosophical concepts developed on the
cypherpunk's email list within a few
years the movement was reborn with a new
generation committed to enhancing
personal freedom and privacy with
cryptographic tools
it's like discovering an oasis when
you're lost in the desert it's bitcoin
that's single-handedly responsible for
the current
wave of cypherpunk
activity
it's always messier than visionaries can
anticipate because reality is bigger
than anyone head
we're still on the road in the quest to
build architectures that amplify human
freedoms and protect us from the
dynamics in the other direction